what um
maybe you could speak to love and
relationship in your own life but in
general
if we look at alice shrugged if we look
at fountainhead
and maybe this is going to become a
therapy session for lex but also just
looking at your own life
in a form of advice how can you be
uh auroric weird and type character and
do it
live your life to the fullest in in
in creating the most amazing things that
you're able to create
and yet have others in your life that
you give yourself to in terms of loving
them fully and having a family
having kids but just even just the love
of your life kind of thing
um how do you balance those things
together
is there any anything to say i'll say
one thing because then i'll defer your
own because he's the one who's married
here
i don't think it's a balance i think
they complement each other and feed off
each other so it's like how do you
balance having shoes and pants it's like
no you want both you you want it all and
having a great partner
who thinks you're a badass and then
sometimes they're on the stage and
you're like oh my i'm married to a
badass that's
that's the goal yeah am i wrong no
absolutely it feeds off of each other
it's energetic it's completely
synergetic the problem that people have
i think
where they get into challenges is when
they view them as opposites right
work or family well if you don't work
the family you can't fun finance the
family but more than that
why is your love gonna why is your wife
gonna love you right what are the
virtues that you're bringing if you
don't
maximize your own potential if you don't
live the best life that you can live
what is it to love and if she doesn't do
the same thing
why do you love her so so you don't get
this conflict between
work and you know how do i have a
balanced life of course you have a
balanced life
you balance it based on your values and
it's never going to be the same the
balance is
you know the the time you spend at work
and with family when you're young or
when you have
little kids or when they're grown up is
all going to be different it's going to
depend
on your priorities at the point but it's
all going to feed off of each other
so maybe another word outside of balance
is sacrifice do you think
relationship involves sacrifice or not i
know what he's doing i know he's i think
he's trolling you he's controlling he's
a big troll lex is the biggest troll on
twitter
ever deal with it never sacrifice
sacrifice so i'm going to define it yeah
okay so sacrificing
can i say one thing before we get
sidebar rand
ran had a good example we're talking
about balance so she was married to this
guy frank o'connor he was not a cerebral
he was not intellectual that's fine she
was in love with him
and i met someone who had been friends
with rand and a lot of times she'd have
these conversations with her acolytes to
like four in the morning about the most
cerebral topics
and i said and he would always bring
them food he'd stay up and kind of sit
there in a corner
and i go when this was happening was he
sitting there like oh god here goes
crazy old iron and i just gotta be bored
and they go absolutely not he was so
proud of her
he was so excited in fact when she got a
lot of money from i think
selling red pawn which was her
screenplay which never produced he told
her
you can buy any kind of fur coat as long
as it's mink
he wouldn't he's like you earned this
celebrate it so that was a good example
that's a good relationship absolutely
no sacrifice is the get is the giving of
a high of a value
and expecting either nothing or
something less in return
you don't do that in a love relationship
your love relationship is a sense a
trade
you're constantly trading you're not
trading materially but you're trading
spiritually
imagine if i only gave my wife if i gave
spiritually and materially only in one
direction
i'd get sick of it she'd get sick of it
it would never last
it has to be in give and take constantly
in different ways
right different values it's not it's not
a monetary exchange
but it's constantly you're giving and
you're you're receiving and you're
giving
right and it's it's it's gotta that's
gotta be in balance and
and i know a lot of relationship with
that gets out of bounds right
and one party feels like they're giving
all the time the sacrificing
they're giving more than they're
receiving in a sense and it's over
right so now people use the word
sacrifice like like jordan peterson
sometimes he
uses it both ways right that's the
problem people use it i don't know him
personally you know john peterson i said
i didn't call him jordan
yeah uh he uses in his talks as
sometimes he uses it as just as i
described it
uh and he's supportive of that like the
sacrifice jesus made right
and sometimes he uses his investment but
it's
it's not if you if you're giving some
giving money now
expecting a bigger return in the future
that's not a sacrifice that's an
investment that's why we have two
concepts for that and the same is true
you know if my wife is ill
and i mean you know i've got a whole
relationship build around
what i'm giving it's not that i'm not
getting anything back when i'm getting
back
is that she is recovering right is that
she
is she's still alive or whatever it is
that that i'm keeping that's the value
that i'm getting in return if i'm not
getting that
why am i doing it because i signed a
contract a long time ago
um so it's uh it's it's not a sacrifice
children are not cyclists if i don't go
to the movies because i stay with my
home with my kids
it's because i love my kids more than i
love going to the movies right
and if i love going to the movies more
than i live staying with the kids then
get a babysitter
or don't have kids which is the better
better approach
because every question yeah who did what
book did ayn rand say is the most evil
book in all serious literature it was
anna correct
and the reason it was that book which i
haven't read please correct me if i get
the plot wrong
rand was saying is the plot is a guy
who's a big shot i think
he marries a stupid girl who has nothing
of value to offer him for
at all and she ends up killing herself
whereas rand's version we can take this
out of the romantic context
it i am delighted when i could be of use
to my friends
it is makes me feel wonderful and not in
a kind of parasitic way it's just like
that i'm at a certain point where they
call me up they're having a problem and
i've helped them with that problem anna
karenina he
gives up the love of his life
the amazing girl he has an affair with
her outside of marriage
taints her is married to the s to the
stupid but she gives him the prestige
and everything oh
oh that's clearly very anti-racist yeah
yeah yeah and the and the the
the the the the smart real the one
he he loves she commits suicide in there
okay i got it wrong so it's
it's it's um it's it's about him
choosing mediocrity and nothingness over
this amazing
quality so pursuing your values is so
crucial
so don't sacrifice that doesn't mean
that if you want to eat chinese and she
want to eat italian you don't once in a
while eat italian on that day right
that's
that's just that's silly right that's
not a
sacrifice not in the sense in which
we're talking about that's
you know it doesn't mean don't
compromise it doesn't mean don't
compromise on
on the day-to-day stuff it means don't
compromise them all values doesn't
you don't compromise on the big stuff
and you never
and and you never sacrifice and that way
you you have a relationship that's built
as equals
and and as you admire each other and
love
at the end of the day as a response to
value
if you stop undermining your own value
the person who loves you will stop or
will stop loving you or love you less
if you love yourself less they you know
you have to jay and also said just in
order to say i love you you have to be
able to say the i
right you have to you have to be
somebody you have to know yourself you
have to have
value and it's a love is a love is a
profound emotional
response to value
you